[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec la une cette
semaine la colère des producteurs de
lait pas assez rémunérés à leur goût ils
réclament une hausse des prix des ventes
reportage à suivre de vosges télévision
dans quelques instants dans ce journal
des prix qui grimpent et des habitudes
modifié l'inflation n'est pas sans
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français alors pour s' adapter certains
changent leurs habitudes alimentaires
nous montrera tv7 depuis un marché
bordelais sont témoignages racontent
l'horreur de l'histoire 97 ans ginette
kolinka et l'une des dernières escales
paix du camp d'auschwitz pour entretenir
le devoir de mémoire elle raconte sa vie
aux plus jeunes et vous allez voir un
reportage dans l'est réalisée il ya
quelques jours par moselle tv qui a
suivi son intervention auprès de lycéens
enfin une visite princière en corse le
prince albert de monaco a inauguré le
nouveau musée archéologique de l'île de
beauté un établissement qui atteste de
l'histoire commune entre les deux rives
de la méditerranée
tous les mérites salaires s'est inspiré
de ce slogan que des agriculteurs
vosgiens ont manifesté leur inquiétude
cette semaine dans un hypermarché ces
derniers ne s'estime pas assez rémunérés
et exigent une hausse du prix du lait
sécheresse et inflation sont notamment
évoqués pour expliquer cette situation
un éclairage d'anthony sap et dan didier
pour vosges télévision
une mobilisation d'agriculteurs dans les
rayons d'une grande surface des images
que l'on a déjà vu à de multiples
reprises et c'est bien là le problème
malgré les lois et galim puis égalise 2
qui doivent garantir une meilleure prise
en compte des coûts de production des
agriculteurs pour leur assurer une
rémunération plus juste ces derniers se
sentent toujours floues et sont venus le
faire savoir ici ah je sais ce lundi
après midi à travers une nouvelle
opération coup de poing sur le prix du
lait égal il nous promettait la
construction du prix à l'endroit comme
on aime le dire c'est à dire on part du
coût de production du producteur et on
arrive à un prix final tandis
qu'aujourd'hui les négociations parle
toujours de prix final hop ça découle en
échelle et puis derrière finalement
c'est toujours le producteur qui fait la
variable d'ajustement on ne jetons pas
le bébé avec l'eau du bain il ya des
choses qui sont allées dans le bon sens
à travers et galim sauf que là nous
sommes dans une situation de marché qui
sont absolument inédites et inattendues
aussi d'autre part il faut qu'on l'a vu
et malheureusement on n'a pas d'autre
choix aujourd'hui que dire si le lait
nous est payé au prix ont continué de
payer bien les élevages laitiers vont
partir entre sécheresse et inflation
effectivement les coûts de production
ont considérablement augmenté ces
derniers mois le calcul est donc simple
pour avoir une rémunération proche de
celle de leurs voisins européens les
producteurs de lait français demandent
que le prix moyen du litre soit
supérieur d'au moins 21 centimes par
rapport à ce que le consommateur paye
aujourd'hui lui acheter dans les
magasins à moins de 1 euro ça ne permet
pas de rémunération du producteur tout
simplement et parce que ce qu'on
constate aussi c'est que nos pays
limitrophes les pays voisins luxembourg
belgique allemagne sont à plus de 20
centimes de plus que nous dans le lait
vendu au consommateur aujourd'hui c'est
des contrats tripartites c'est à dire le
producteur le transformateur est le
distributeur mais seulement le
distributeur et transformateurs parle de
prix aujourd'hui le producteur est
complètement exclue des discussions est
théoriquement si et galim était appliqué
comme elle devrait l'être normalement le
producteur devrait avoir à un prix
décent pour vivre de sa production de
lait cette opération se voulait
pédagogique mais les agriculteurs
comptent bien hausser le ton s'il ne
sont pas rapidement prises au sérieux
ces inquiétudes autour du lait ne sont
pas sans lien bien sûr avec l'inflation
galopante constaté sur de nombreux
produits alimentaires depuis quelques
mois sur les marchés les consommateurs
ont déjà changé leurs habitudes pour
s'adapter à des prix qui ne cessent de
grimper exemple à bordeaux vous allez le
voir avec ce sujet de tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest
face à l'augmentation des prix certains
se serrent la ceinture et réduisent
leurs achats de nourriture les quantités
diminuent ou des produits disparaissent
de leur alimentation en deux manches de
moi je pense pas la viande j'aime bien
si elle est démente j'en mange moins
souvent peut-être je range il faut par
semaine à peu près les bouchers font le
même constat franchement où ils ont
diminué leurs quantités beaucoup
avant ils prenaient un rôti de kilos
deux maintenant et plus au québec kg 800
grammes idem chez les poissonniers dans
les prix ont augmenté de 10 à 20 % la
hausse du carburant fait que les
pêcheurs fortement en mer donc
obligatoirement se seraient percutés sur
la marchandise
du coup est ce que vous avez perdu des
clients forcément
il ya beaucoup ils achètent beaucoup
moins déjà et
13h15 au prix et ceux qui ne renonce à
rien en terme d'alimentation font
d'autres choix est fait pas non plus de
certaines se cochonneries des trucs
inutiles des choses comme ça et moi je
réduis pas un budget d'alimentation qui
peut-être plus haut chez moi que chez
d'autres mais
il ya beaucoup de chose sur lequel on
peut réduire
notre consommation avant de toucher
réalimentation si beaucoup restent
fidèles aux marchés d'autres sont
contraints d'y renoncer sur certains
produits je ne me rediriger vers les
grandes surfaces parce que justement
c'est un peu trop cher sur les marchés
et malgré ça le budget augmente je
dirais peut-être de 5 euros en moyenne
par semaine en sachant que je n'achète
pas de viande
c'est vraiment que des produits laitiers
des légumes des féculents sont là deux
produits qui ne sont pas
entrée cher de base est là je trouve que
même avec ça ça augmente et
voilà et si vous chercher d'autres
solutions pratiques pour faire des
économies pourquoi ne pas vous tourner
vers le marché de l'occasion il est en
plein essor depuis quelques années et
dans la somme une boutique de jouets
s'est même spécialisée dans ce type de
vente avec 300 références disponibles
bonne pour l'environnement et le
porte-monnaie l'initiative séduit de
plus en plus de consommateurs comme a pu
le constater ou à la chaîne de la voix
du nord regardez
et si vous jouez s'offrait une seconde
vie dans cette enseigne figurines
voitures et autres jeux de société ont
quitté leur coffre à jouets pour
retourner à la vente
la tendance en particulier ce sont les
playmobil ça plaît beaucoup
effectivement aux enfants en l'autre
tendance également ce sont les livres
pour enfants
puisque je les vends à 50% du prix du
neuf à l'heure de l'inflation la chasse
aux bonnes affaires devient monnaie
courante sur internet via les réseaux
sociaux ou dans les enseignes
spécialisées
les consommateurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux à se tourner vers les produits
de seconde main la vie est tellement
cher que balla du coup on prend ce qu'on
peut pour eux un pas trop cher on va
dire ça nous permet de trouver des lego
qu'on trouve plus en commerce et puis
autant remettre à l'ordre du jour
d'effacer inutile de claix chose par
terre à labenne donc on aime bien aussi
recycle l'occasion un modèle à la fois
économique et éco-responsable selon
lagence de la transition écologique 100
mille tonnes de jouets finirait chaque
année à la poubelle alors dans sa
boutique fabien delrue propose aux
particuliers de racheter leurs vieux
jouets environ 25% du prix à 9 c'est du
gagnant gagnant que ce soit pour le
client qui vient me vendre effectivement
ces jouets ou ces jeux puisqu'il repart
tout de suite avec avec son argent et
pour moi ça me permet aussi de garantir
à mon client final est bien la qualité
en fait déjouer puisqu'ils vont être
contrôlés ils vont être nettoyées si
besoin est complétée également merci à
vous
il y a trois ans quatre français sur dix
se disaient convertis aux produits de
seconde main un chiffre toujours à la
hausse sûr que ces jouets auront encore
de belles histoires à raconter
sans transition dans ce journal
découvrons à présent le témoignage
poignant d'une rescapée du camp
d'auschwitz ginette kolinka 97 ans a
survécu au pire elle se déplace
aujourd'hui partout en france à la
rencontre des plus jeunes pour raconter
son histoire bouleversante
objectif transmettre et entretenir le
devoir de mémoire des horreurs de la
seconde guerre mondiale elle était il ya
quelques jours dans l'est pour
s'exprimer et échanger avec 400 lycéens
et jean mi longs pour modèle la
télévision a pu recueillir leurs
témoignages
le témoignage et fort la salle
silencieuse
2h30 durant ginette kolinka raconte son
histoire dans les détails les plus
sombres comment ne pas être bouleversé
j'ai vécu avec beaucoup d'émotion parce
que j'ai quand même eu les larmes aux
yeux je pense les trois quarts d'heure
de cette conférence de part son
explication son témoignage et aussi
parce que basque elle raconte ses c'est
un peu les horreurs de la guerre je suis
un peu ce sentiment qu'elle a réussi à
partager tout en n'ayant ce caractère un
peu comique très positif comme dame et
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment incroyable juive
a été victime de la haine ginette
kolinka reste néanmoins une femme plein
d'humour son intervention aura marqué
les lycéens c'est mieux d'avoir des
témoignages de personnes qui ont tout
vécu
que de se servir de manuels
moi je dis j'ai souffert ces tarifs cet
affreux c'est l'enfer qu'on a vécu et
s'il sera un journal on dit elle on lui
bat est là c'est sûr que moi ce que j'ai
dit a plus de valeur que ce qu'ont
longtemps discrète sur son passé de
déportés elle sillonne aujourd'hui la
france entière pour transmettre son
expérience à 97 ans elle est une des
dernières ambassadrice de la mémoire des
nazis ils ont commis des erreurs à
l'époque donc c'est important de faire
transmettre le message est de ne pas
recommencer les mêmes erreurs on espère
en tout cas que ça ne se reproduira
jamais parce que les hommes sont tous
ces gosses à transmettre pour ne surtout
jamais oublier voilà la tâche que s'est
confié ginette kolinka à leur tour les
jeunes générations deviendront ainsi les
passeurs de mémoire
écoliers collégiens ou lycéens tout le
monde a retrouvé son rythme éducative
depuis la rentrée parmi les élèves de
retour en classe certains d'entre eux
sont en situation de handicap en milieu
ordinaire ou spécialisés ont fait le
poids sur leur rentrée avec ses enjeux
avec un v l'isard journalistes pour viol
si thani qui fait partie du groupe la
dépêche
des couloirs larges aux tables réglable
dans ce collège et lycée tout est pensé
pour les enfants en situation de
handicap à ramonville aux portes de
toulouse cet établissement spécialisé
accueille 160 élèves ils sont dix par
classe maximum le programme scolaire est
identique à celui du may ordinaire en
revanche il ya tout un tas d'ateliers
éducatifs qui n'existe pas en milieu
ordinaire on a ici en fait en plus du
scolaire un accompagnement médico-social
qui est composé en fait d'une partie
soir éducative et éducatif un
accompagnement spécialisé donc qui
séduit ses élèves on n'est pas jugée on
est on est en fait ici on est tous
pareils on a tous un handicap et on vit
tous la même chose et je pense que la
principale qualité de jean lagarde cela
solidarité avec les élèves contrairement
à fait salle 2 ambrose enfants
choisissent la scolarisation en milieu
ordinaire
ils sont alors suivis par des
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap dit à us h autre possibilité
les classes ulis des unités localisées
pour l'inclusion scolaire 24 élèves ont
bénéficié dans cette école
carcassonnaise c'est l'ensemble de la
communauté qui doit s'intéresser aux
élèves en situation de handicap pour
notre académie j'ai donné deux priorités
cette année la qualité de l'accueil et
la qualité du parcours des élèves au
total quinze mille enfants en situation
de handicap sont accompagnés dans
l'académie de montpellier
voilà et c'est bien connu les petits
comme les grands ne sont généralement
pas de grands fans de la dictée c'est
pour rendre plus agréable et accessible
l'exercice qu'une association organise
des dictées géante partout en france
dernier passage à limoges un reportage
sans faute et dans la bonne humeur dans
l'indre euros pour 7 à l'image de la
télévision sur place
attendue c'est une première à limoges
mais c'est au moins la 401e dictée pour
tous avec un peu plus de 50 participants
de tous âges réunis près du centre jean
le bail pour mesurer la réussite
dé feutrine organisé par mal
d'événements dans nos quartiers en
région parisienne dans le 95 argenteuil
et on a eu pas mal de sollicitations par
rapport aux mamans on a beaucoup vu des
tournois de foot ddd événement caritatif
etc on voulait apporter justement une
touche une touche ludique à ce genre
d'événement donc d'où est venue l'idée
de la dictée pour tout ce qu'on s'est
dit ces affaires à limoges monde partage
le moment de on va dire de solidarité un
petit peu qui peut se créer c'est à ce
moment là et puis
ouais un vrai moment de partage on
retrouvera une pléiade dans combat avec
trois niveaux de primaire à seniors en
passant par le collège ce fut presque
une balade scolaire suis vraiment amusé
il ya deux mondes pour lesquelles je
doute évidemment pléiade et bigard et
puis j'ai toujours été à l'aise avec
l'orthographe des pions jeunesse ça va
on appréhende toujours quand on organise
dans une ville qu'on n'a pas forcément
eu d'événement auparavant les
franchement l'organisation a été nickel
et je remercie beaucoup l'association
bougez bougez pour l'accueil et toute la
logistique a été mis en place avant mon
arrivée un rendez vous est pris pour une
nouvelle organisation l'année prochaine
après deux années difficiles marquées du
sceau du coc vide les associations font
également leur rentrée en ce mois de
septembre un moment évidemment cruciale
pour tenter de séduire un maximum de
public à leur activité
l'enjeu est d'abord financier pour ces
structures fragilisées par la crise
alors comment se porte le secteur
associatif éléments de réponse au forum
des associations des clayes-sous-bois
dans les yvelines avec julien leroy
journalistes pour tv 60,18 la chaîne des
yvelines
une année de renaissance c'est ce que
constate le secteur associatif après
deux années de pandémie de kobe de 19 ce
dimanche au forum des clayes-sous-bois
les 150 associations de la ville ont pu
observer une hausse des adhésions en
cette rentrée le forum de l'année de
l'année dernière a été vraiment un forum
de reprise où les adhérents étaient
relativement frileux alors que cette
année le premier tour que j'ai fait au
niveau des stands d'associations
démontre qu'il y a une réelle reprise au
niveau des adhésions l'association les
clés gr propose des activités de
gymnastique rythmique pas de baisse
significative pour ses 200 adhérents
cela a permis à l'association de
maintenir son budget annuel de 60000
euros
comme on pouvait plus faire de
compétition en fait on a eu
on a eu des finances qui ont été plutôt
positives mais l'année dernière on a
beaucoup dépensé parce qu'on a dû
proposer beaucoup de réduction à nos
adhérents suite à tout ce qui avait tout
ce qu'ils avaient perdu là on a on est
revenu à un financement normal la
situation s'améliore aujourd'hui au
niveau des bénévoles la structure on
avait perdu plus de 60% durant la
pandémie pour l'union de retraités des
clayes-sous-bois la période qu'ovide
était très compliqué pour ce public
vulnérable l'association qui organise
des activités comme des lotos ou encore
dégoûté à des perdu 50 adhérents sur ces
200 monde ça a vraiment été très dur
pour l'association personne ne voulait
ne voulait aller à la salle lorsque
sarah est ouvert cette journée du forum
a permis à l'association de recruter une
vingtaine de nouveaux adhérents avec
plus de 300000 euros de subventions
versées chaque année les
clayes-sous-bois sûr que le secteur
associatif s'est bien maintenue dans la
vie cette édition 2022 du forum des
associations est revenue à des niveaux
de fréquentation d'avant crise et need
et
[Applaudissements]
sans transition direction la loire dans
cette édition où les motards ont décidé
de sensibiliser les élus à leurs
problématiques routière passage mal
entretenues piéton ou automobiliste pas
assez attentifs l'opération motard d'un
jour doit permettre d'engager un
dialogue constructif alors cela at il
fonctionné réponse avec anthony vers
pillon de l'action de tl7 la chaîne de
la loire
la rencontre a débuté par un briefing de
ce à quoi les élus devaient être
attentif entre dos d'âne qui ne sont pas
aux normes et zone de travaux pas assez
nettoyer les motards ont voulu adresser
quelques messages aujourd'hui dans une
voiture on met ses mains sur le volant à
l'aîné tonga les téléphones il pianote
et ainsi de suite et puis ben il rate un
trottoir il va péter ça j'en sais pas
grave que nous si on rate un trottoir on
est tout de suite au road au tapis quoi
quand ils réfléchissent infrastructures
aménagement routier ou qualité des
routes qu'ils puissent appréhender la
particularité du deux-roues premier
arrêt justement cette zone de travaux
qui pose problème de trop nombreux
gravier jonchent le sol alors que les
machines ne sont plus là mais aussi à
ces plots pour empêcher de tourner et
qui sont un vrai danger notamment par
temps de pluie cette cession permet donc
d'engager le dialogue embêtant à quelque
chose de physique ça va dissuader
l'objectif c'est aussi de dissuader
parce que pour
pour garantir la sécurité il faut pas
que ce désir de protection il a franchi
ce le piéton sa responsabilité aussi
parce qu'aujourd'hui le piéton il se
jette sur la voirie pomme sans regarder
avec son écouteurs ou son téléphone et
après une quarantaine de kilomètres le
regard des élus évolue forcément sur ces
problématiques et c'est vrai qu'un
particulier dans certains endroits avec
les plaques sur le sol sur les sur la
voirie on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un danger
que quelque part lorsqu'on en voiture on
ne contrôle pas tout à fait ou qu'on
évalue pas tout à fait c'est une
préoccupation constante pour les élus
comme pour les gens des services mais il
est bon de temps en temps d'avoir un
petit rappel de vaccin sur les
problématiques des deux roues qui sont
pas celles des 4 euros ni même des
piétons notez que d'autres rencontres de
ce type au est également avoir lieu pour
les cyclistes notamment
réduire sa consommation de plastique
pour protéger la planète l'objectif est
désormais connu de tous il est même
ancré dans la loi pour certains
plastiques à usage unique notamment
comme les pailles réduire notre
empreinte environnementale c'est aussi
l'ambition d'une agricultrice dans la
sarthe cassandra bons mots c'est son nom
est dirigeante d'une entreprise qui
produit des pailles 100% écologique
grâce à elle fini la pollution le temps
d'un cocktail place à une paille naturel
fabriqué à base de bras de seigle
explications d'enzo maubert pour lm tv
sarthe
au départ il y à ces brins de seigle
qu'il faut éplucher et envoyé dans ce
grand conteneur à l'intérieur une
machine de pointe au secret bien gardé
qui transforme un simple brin pas une
paille made in sarthe elle prend le bras
en entier elle le visionnent elles
repèrent les morceaux de pâques qui nous
intéresse dans quelle mesure elle prend
le diamètre et après elle coupe ensuite
quand c coupé on a un système de prise
qui va triées par taille pour nous
permettre derrière ranger en panier
gagnez du temps un temps précieux car il
faut ensuite nettoyé et trier les
tailles à la main on repère les pikes
ont été cassés à tous avec toutes les
manipulations on repère les pays qui ont
un défaut une tâche et puis on repère
aussi les tailles lorsqu'on parle des
petites différences de taille on
s'enivre l'attention
résultat près de 200 mille pailles sorte
de l'entreprise chaque mois et selon
cassandra bourmaud c'est l'alternative
idéale face aux plastiques et aux cartes
on ya pas de traitement il n'y a rien on
n a même pas mis ce vernis on est
vraiment elle a sa couleur naturelle
elle est brillante de nature mais en
plus bas elle résiste à toutes les
boissons chaudes toutes les boissons
froides elle peut même absorber des
boissons épaisse comme disent aussi des
choses comme ça commercialisée dans la
grande distribution est vendue auprès
des professionnels la petite paille
sarthoise est attendue au salon
international de l'alimentation à paris
en octobre une belle vitrine pour
l'entreprise qui espère à terme produire
50 millions de paille par an
manger des produits locaux et de qualité
qui n'en rêve pas pour ses repas
difficile néanmoins d'accéder à des
aliments de proximité dans certaines
zones rurales où les commerces se font
de plus en plus rares alors pour combler
ce manque dans le val d'oise une petite
commune vient d'installer un
distributeur ouvert 24 heures sur 24 et
7 jours sur 7 les habitants peuvent
ainsi acheter des légumes viennoiseries
ou miel locaux quand ils le souhaitent
une initiative saluée par les habitants
comme a pu le constater raphaël utah et
elisa un état de la chaîne via 95
une envie de fraises ou de viennoiseries
ses casiers installé sur le parking de
la mairie d'avesnes en distribuer à
toute heure du jour et de la nuit
emina à bernoise depuis quatre ans se
procure environ deux fois par semaine
ces produits du terroir favori ce jeu
qui tarde souvent donc les boutiques
sont fermées déjà pour ça pour le pain
par exemple et puis là les produits de
la région puisque j'aime beaucoup la
moutarde de la région l'huile pour
manger local les 870 habitants de ce
petit village du vexin n'avait pas
tellement le choix le marché a lieu
seulement tous les deuxièmes samedis du
mois et la boucherie demeure la seule
boutique de proximité de la commune
c'est important pour les consommateurs
mensuel du archers de pouvoir avoir
régulièrement leur leur produit donc on
a dit ben pourquoi pas des casiers c'est
des choses qui existent est plutôt à la
ferme mais comme on a des petites
exploitations ici c'est compliqué pour
les agriculteurs de porter eux-mêmes ces
financements un point de vente
supplémentaires et davantage de
visibilité pour les six producteurs
locaux qui propose ici leur produit des
fruits des légumes des viennoiseries des
biscuits et même de l'huile et du miel
c'est quand même un village très passant
c'est vexant tout le monde passe ont
visité
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas arriver avec
monde au total c'est quasi ont coûté
près de soixante quinze mille euros dont
plus de la moitié a été subventionné par
l'état dans le cadre du plan france
relance un maraîcher qui a dit qu'il
aurait dit si fait savoir qu on met des
pros il a vendu et s'il doit
approvisionner au pas ces casses et côté
prix les clients déboursent la même
somme que marcher ou à la ferme puisque
aucune commission supplémentaire n'est
prélevée en france ce sont plus de 500
distributeurs alimentaires comme celui
ci qui ont été mises en place dont une
dizaine en ile-de-france des produits
locaux la bretagne ne manquent pas alors
parmi les richesses culinaires de cette
région il y a bien sûr l'élevage des
moules soit la mytiliculture selon le
terme professionnel c'est pour en savoir
un peu plus sur ce milieu qu'une
entreprise locale organise des sorties
en bateau au milieu des pieux où se
trouvent les moules
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
tébéo la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
des sorties qui intéresse autant les
locaux que les touristes propos
recueillis par mathilde de kenner de
tébéo
imaginez-vous effectivement en convient
certes mais dans une eau à peut-être 8,9
degrés de voir plonger pour faire un
noeud à la main surtout les pieux que
vous voyez là on propose justement aux
gens de découvrir bas à l'envers du
décor comment on produit les moules
généralement les gens sensés contents
ils sont même assez surpris de la
difficulté du métier quand on voit le
prix le prix d'un kilo de moules le
travail qui a à faire à part ça c'est
vraiment pas cher à kg de moules c'est
un métier qui doit être mis en valeur
voilà de profiter de des ressources qui
a chez nous lustres satra trouve
intéressant allez restons en bretagne
pour découvrir à présent l'un des plus
beaux hôtels de la région le nez si
cette bâtisse rénovée il ya tout juste
quatre ans vient de recevoir un label
prestigieux est rarement décerner une
récompense qui n'a pas été vous allez
voir sans effet sur sa fréquentation un
sujet de claire guyot de la rédaction de
tv air à rennes
perché sur la presqu'île du nez c'est
cette bâtisse du 19e siècle est bien
connue des promeneurs ouvert en juillet
2018 après un an de travaux cette
ancienne colonie de vacances est devenu
un hôtel 4 étoiles de charme à
l'atmosphère chaleureuse où chaque
fenêtre s'ouvre sur la mer alors nous
nous trouvons dans une de nos 17
chambres du coup de l'hôtel du nez c'est
chaque chambre sa décoration sa propre
décoration tous les objets de chaque
chambre sont chine et c sont des objets
voilà un peu vintage qui rappelle du
coup cet esprit maison de famille depuis
début août le château se distingue en
devenant l'unique hôtel breton à obtenir
le prestigieux label small luxury hotels
of the world un label attribué aux
établissements de luxe intimiste avec
moins de 50 chambres ils ne sont que
cinq cents dans le monde et 50 en france
à l'avoir décroché un gage de visibilité
notamment à l'international la
répercussion a été très rapide en fait
on a
à peine eu la belle au début août nos
ventes se sont ouverts sur le site
internet de baisse et lâche et on a eu
déjà dans le premier - une quinzaine de
vente spécifiques fait vias
cette passerelle là de quoi motiver
l'équipe de 40 professionnels et 30
saisonniers l'été valable quatre ans le
label sera bientôt visible sur la façade
du château avec une plaque de bronze
officielle
[Musique]
voilà on referme ce journal en corse où
le prince albert de monaco s'est rendu
il ya quelques jours pour inaugurer le
musée archéologique de mariana
l'établissement rassemble près de 500
objets retrouvés près de la commune de
lucciana et témoigne de l'histoire du
site depuis le vième siècle avant
jésus-christ jusqu'au moyen âge écoutez
à ce propos le prince albert au micro de
markovic yeli pour vyas télévisée en
corse comme ce galet team il m'avait
parlé de ce projet j'ai diva d'écouter
ces moments extraordinaires et puis de
de comprendre un petit peu tout le tout
l'étendu de deux fouilles qui ont déjà
eu lieu mais il des fouilles aussi
potentiel ça sera vraiment un lieu très
très importance pour
non seulement pour l'archéologie mais
pour la compréhension de de toutes
origines méditerranéennes et de tout ce
qui a fait le ces échanges
extraordinaires entre toutes les peuples
de la méditerranée
voilà merci de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin de ce grand jt des territoires on
se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition horvath
[Musique]